前面刺绣字母 胶印图案的这个
胶印字母 胶印字母 前面刺绣字母
来 胸围
胸围104126
104126的胸围 长度是65
长度65
这个9块 9块扣个5
这个卫衣
棉婚纺 婚纺的
9块9块给你们 扣5 扣5
9块钱 扣个5
来 这个
这个是一个灰白条 灰白条
棉的 棉的这一条裙
棉的一个裙 看下细标
看下细标 里面内衬是棉100的
外面是棉多少 我给你看看
没有标了 没有标了
没看见标了 这个
不确定外面是不是棉100的
我忘了 这个内衬是棉100
内衬是个棉100的
上身没有内衬 裙子有内衬
看见没有
我看连一圈
来 胸围
胸围是96 98
96 98
来 长度105
长度105
这个29块 扣5 扣5
29 29 扣5 扣5
29块 扣个5 扣个5
29块 扣个5
长度62
这个给你买29块
扣2扣2
远领远领
领口双层
29块
扣2扣2
三标齐全的这个
后面开叉一个
这只29
扣个2扣个2
29块
拿这一款
这个标了一个2的
这个是
标了一个2的
这个牌子
这个牌子的
一个白色背心裙
白色一个背心裙
这个有S有M
这个是2L
这个尺码大
后面有松铃
有斯马克松铃
有一个绑带
胸围
胸围90
拉伸108
长度
长度的话是119了
这个29块
扣9扣9
这里张了
一点
这是39的
这个好的也有
好的给你们找一件去
这里也有点脏
看到没有
回去过压水就掉了
这个都沾的灰
是啥家伙
是粘的贴到地上
扫了一下
应该
这个29块
扣2扣2
29块
扣个2扣个2
背心裙背心裙
裂了
lar
在孔子
Beauty
带了
还在
这么
使得
有点
快点
力
来这个格子的
蓝色格子的这件上衣
这有黄格子
这个是一个蓝色格子
腰上后面松紧
前面是有一排扣子
腰上后面有松紧
收腰收的很好
看看
搭裙子搭裤子
这个都很美
很好看
显瘦的很
来这个胸围
胸围92104
来这个衣长
衣长58
来这个19块扣8
1919扣8扣8
来这样很好
显腰瘦的很
来这个2929扣8
SML三个尺码
这一个两个颜色
29块
来这个灰色
灰色一个短款的一个
一个一个卫衣
再一次啊
中好中好
这个是一个灰色
一个短款卫衣
一样胸围原价29的
胸围102120
102120的胸围来一长一长45
19扣个5
19块
这个是棉灰纺应该
毛圈棉的
毛圈毛圈的这个是
来这个1919扣5扣5
19块19块扣5扣5
灰色灰色的这个
1919扣5
来这个大香蕉的一个家居上衣
大香蕉的一个家居上衣
胸围胸围的话是116118
长度70
9块扣9
9块钱扣9扣9家居上衣
大香蕉的这个护品没有几件了
这个护品了
品了9块9块扣9扣9这个面料很丝滑
很舒服的这个9块扣9扣9
来这个外搭蓝色这个牌子
是不是这个牌
这个牌子不
这个标的是一个child的child
扣u扣u
蓝色蓝色的一个外搭
这一块没有扣的
没有扣眼
没有扣没扣眼
吸线直直的
来这个胸围
胸部106106140
长度106106140
长度57
这个9块9块给你们炸一个扣8扣8
9块扣个8面料很软很柔软的
这个吸线真直的没有扣没有扣眼
9块9块扣8扣8
9块给你们了
扣个8
来这个
这个是一个灰色和一个和一个白色条纹的
这一块短袖这样子的
灰色和白色
红色和白色条纹的
看看特别凉很垂
不用打理的
胸围102110
102110来长度
长度57
9块扣个8
这个袖子的话
它是这样的一个袖子
这样一个袖子打了一个折子
打了一个结好像是
这样一个袖
7分的是5分的这个袖子
9块9块扣1扣1
扣1扣1
9块9块扣个1
面料很垂很舒服的
来这一块
这个标的是一个M码锯纸的
M码一个锯纸
这个标的是一个黑色
踩了一个白色明线的
黑色踩白色明线
胸围看看
是116126
116126的胸围
来长度
长度75
这个有要的19
1919扣个5
19块19块
扣5扣5
19元
19块扣个5
扣5扣5
来这一块
这个标的是一个
棉的一条裤
这个标S嘛
棉82
锯纸16
棉82的这个牌子
然后里面是毛圈的
那天有个小姐姐
扣了一条这个裤
哈林裤
腰围66
能拉伸90
腿围112126
当长36
裤长86
这个39
扣3
39块扣3扣3
卡齐黄的
卡齐黄的这一条裤
39块扣3扣3
39扣个3
这个刚刚都过了的
过了的我就不过了
有破完了那个
我就不过了
来这一条这个棉95
圈子5这个牌子
这个蓝色蓝色的这一条
蓝色
棉95圈子5腰围
腰围7482
腿围94108
当长34
扣长99
这个9块
9块钱扣9扣9
这个属于一个蓝色
这个标的是
棉95圈子5的
9块9块
扣5扣5
9块ents
9块♥
9块 什么
consultation
这个开饭
一 San
三
四
dancer
B香
地
那有呢
还有两个
哪儿了
我收
收早上的钱
三姨给我这个回家了
她说她有两盒
安鬼女天赐愿意了
初点下午五点多
老师才通知
四五点的时候才通知
说天赐愿意
第二天九点半开始
天赐愿意
该上高中了
总考考完了吗
来这个
这个格子的一个小衬衣
下午休息
昨天天天了
天天天
我还
我还在用
也
这个
分东西
我冻結了
她没冻好
会没有
可以在这里
她过节日
几十分钟
那一天我说人说
你能有那么凶的
我给她拿了她没写得好
她让她开个章
我管你我得开章吧
就买个支
后来一看
老了起来
还换了个东西
我没拿
我前两天就买了
前两天七天
以前是十天就买了
现在是五天
快到下午了
有没有买到五天
差不多了
过来谁能来那天卖的最多
卖三十多件
过来又能搬回来
我回来那天卖的最多
我回来卖的那个有个新鲜的口蜜
天然滴滴
滴滴的那种黄油
回来的那个
大年轻的
就那年轻的
就那年多
那个新鲜的口蜜
五六件就一滴滴这个
这样的一样
卖了五件
现在也起点不复杂的
不复杂的
大事吧
我这老爷
你说千
三千
一百八
不远的
来这个胸围
胸围九十
九十九十四
来一个衣裳
衣裳的话七十
来这个十九十九扣一扣一
棉呢
一个格子光聊天去了
来这个十九十九扣五扣五
没有标了
这个不确定棉多少
格子的一个蓝色衬衣
这个是男士的
男士的
十九十九扣一扣一给你们
十九扣一
这一块
这个是一个黄色连衣裙
来这个腰上有sony
然后有一个腰带
叠子摆着的一款连衣裙
装袖装袖的这个
来这个胸围看一下
胸围的话是九十六一二
九十六一二
来这个裙长
群场群场是118群场118
来这个有药的29扣8
原价59的这个圈
现在给你买29能穿扣8扣8
2929扣8扣8这一款